so today we're going to focus on one of
the top players in the US who definitely
was born in the 21st century these guys
who were born in 2000 I don't I don't
want to do the math and it's a wonder
Liang and a wonder has gotten a lot
better lately and he's feed a rating is
over 2450 and his USCF rating is over
twenty five fifty he came second in the
Junior Championship and he's two-time
gold medalist at the World Youth if he
plays in the World Youth this year which
starts at about 10 days in Soviet
Georgia former Soviet Georgia then he
might get a third gold medal
unprecedented okay so I'm going to show
excerpts from his games because I think
if I show the whole game that's too much
for this audience and then the last go
I'm going to show is for many years ago
when as an eight-year-old he beat an
international master but we'll save that
for the end so this game was played
pretty Lisa recently against Constantin
Landa a reasonable grandmaster as I was
called once maybe was one of my
opponents I was never called reasonable
and a Wonder has the white pieces here
and this position Londe decided to
attack by playing the move Knight d7
threatening the e5 pawn it was such a
strong threat that I wonder resigned no
I'm kidding okay if I wonder resigned
then I wouldn't be showing the games and
believe me I searched about 150 games
and he resigned to most of them it's
tough to be nine years old okay
and here the night on d7 does something
very interesting that's bad
it lines up the rook on d1 with a night
on d7 this means the black King has to
stay on the knight and we have potential
discovered attacks so of course when you
analyze any tactics I'm sure you all do
this that means they don't do it is they
analyze checks captures and threats
pollito style unlike jean ippolito
occasionally they win though okay so in
this position white has I'm counting
hold on to captures okay take on c6 and
take out a six and it turns out one of
those captures wins giving the audience
a real easy method to figure out which
one right Luke
okay and the answer is Jenna no Jenna's
not the answer what who you wait were
you born in this century than you could
answer taking the e6 pawn now taking
these six pawn is easy to calculate now
if you're a computer then you'll play
the move rook g8 and if you have the
white pieces you're not afraid of rook
g8 you're like oh boy Knight takes c6
worked like a charm
okay so obviously Lando underestimated
Knight takes c6 and it's a move that you
should see because it captures something
and it unleashes an attack on the knight
and the black King hasn't castled yet
but black was not wary of such threats
because the Queen's are off the board so
he was like all chill he's like I have
my opponents a little kid the Queen's
are off the board I'll use my great
experience to win a long end game and
instead it was one tactic after another
he resigned he's close
but thinking okay so black talk and I'm
thinking if I had the black pieces I
would also miss Knight takes c6 I got
that again and then I would think
forever and ever and ever and ever and I
would play rook g8 and I would lose in a
thousand moves okay but Londa is like
I'm going to lose right now this is
embarrassing
okay so Bishop h5 check and well if the
King goes to f8 we're just losing our
knight white would be a pawn up with a
crushing position so a black held is
Knight okay and now the knight is pinned
because I said so okay even if I didn't
say so it'd be pinned so now everybody
in the audience knows what why did
everyone well you're born in the century
so I'll give you a break
today's b-6 check Black has one legal
move and he is a grandmaster so a Trixie
seven now all the people in this class
are foaming at the mouth
where we have a front desk worker
getting the paper towels right now and
they're like take the rook take the rug
take the rug because they like taking
rooks
however the rook can't move so taking
the rug doesn't make a lot of sense we
should add on to the pressure and if
Paul Morphy was white somehow he would
play rook h1 - D - what a strong player
okay but well now we have more specific
rules in chess we can't do stuff like
that so what what a wonder did he wants
to put more pressure on the night and
instead of doubling the rooks which
takes a long time he actually tried to
do that and make a threat at the same
time because this e six pawn which he
took earlier is not defended so he
played Bishop f7 threatening Bishop
takes six the two bishops are pretty
good and I don't really see a way to
defend the pawn on e6
does anybody here we could illegally
play Knight f8 it's probably not a good
move okay
now the problem is if black wants to
break the pin which he did that his rook
is still trapped so I mean if two super
GM's were playing resigns would be a
good move okay but we don't I don't like
resigning early and obviously black
doesn't either if it was White's turn to
move Bishop takes would be pretty
annoying so black played King to ca
which breaks the pin on the rook so
again we need more workers of the chess
club to give him paper towels because
there was initial takes work mistakes
rook but the rook can't move so there's
that sort of pointless so instead he
pinned the night again and played this
takes e6 right now I will forgive you if
it's your move and you play Bishop takes
rook because that's pretty winning okay
black defender the knight the only way
he knew how rook to d8 okay and now
white can play in Morphy style
because everything's pinned and attacked
I'm guessing every legal move wins
okay Rick gage 3 is a legal move so
that's probably wins right but you
forgot morphe style you know the opera
game or was that before your time what
probably but not you in the morphe game
what did white do it takes d7 he knows
the opera game he loves opera especially
right now black has a problem
well blacks down hold on carry the one I
have a calculator there's a button it
says carry the one hmm Futurama joke
it looks like White's three pawns up all
right ok so black has to take that rook
because you don't want to be down three
pawns although there's not really a good
way to take the rook okay
so instead he resigned but let's take
the rook if we take this way that's a
way right rook g1 Morphy style and the
truth hurts and now we're threatening
Bishop takes rook winning all of black's
pieces what's that
what happens if what I want to hear this
King ba I'm looking but I can't find the
move that doesn't win do you prefer rook
takes d7 or Bishop takes d7 you're from
this century I'm not so you get to
decide yeah okay and so that doesn't
work we could take with this rook okay
and as we say all four I'll say say the
name shows me duck our rook d1 yeah and
the truth hurts it's funny how the rooks
are pinned and can't move okay
and when I'm playing a younger player I
try to avoid tactical sequences because
they see them and I see nothing so I
don't like all that taking and
sacrificing and pinning that's terrible
okay and the computer of course in the
original position after the move Knight
to d7
and I had to get towel and wipe off the
computer it was like Knight takes c6
Knight takes c6 then it was like White's
winning although I did play rook g8 for
black because it saw that these Forster
moves were really really bad for but for
black and blacks Bishop's do nothing
except the Bishop on b7 which is
trapping the black king so it does
something again so that was a crushing
victory for a wonder one of many we're
going to see today and black resign very
nice so here's another a wonder game
against another Grandmaster let's see
which Grandmaster wasn't ah let's go
find out against CAD rich I've heard of
him okay and this was that in
Philadelphia I think after the world
open that's a norm tournament now it's
clear to everybody that White's winning
for two reasons you wouldn't like the
computer says it's equal because white
has Queen and Bishop against Queen and
Knight and more importantly White has a
bishop on f1 yes okay now black has a
passed pawn but blacks King is a bit
suspicious
I prefer White's King okay and a wonder
after rookie seven stopping ripped e7
check played Queen a1 check okay now you
got to be careful if you have black here
because you're going to get checkmated
if your King goes to the back rank
there's coming down even though the
Queen's defending it although King f8
Queen h8 looks pretty good you got it
like that and I think if the King goes
to GA probably rook d5 is good okay so
you play King aged six now the computer
plays Queen f6 double question mark okay
that's why the computer is not one of
the top juniors in the country if not
the world a wonder is a wonder it knows
a very important rule in chess which I'm
sure Alex Marla can explain always you
can guess
queen c2z illegal what no no always
repeat ah so wonder played queen c1
check and then queen a1 check and then
Queen f6 there's like that's a fine
player right and if my student play
Queen f6 immediately fired no amount of
bunny could bring them back
you could try send me as much money as
you can and we'll see what happens okay
so after Queen f6 blacks King isn't
doing so well but he has very good
defense oh wait a minute no he doesn't
okay so we're threatening Queen takes
rook and this King is not doing well and
he played Queen c7 finally getting his
Queen off the side now the computer
wants to play Queen f8 check and says
whites winning and it doesn't like a
wonders move as much because black has
some tricky defense where he's barely
losing
however since black didn't find the
tricky defense his move was much better
game and anybody who's a fan of Patrick
wolf or Matthew Larson will know that
white played g4 okay
he's like Patrick whoa I don't know who
that is but Matt Larson g4 okay and now
the computer wants to play some move
like rook to e8 some move that nobody
would ever play okay and instead and
obviously in time trouble and whites
threatening g5 and G takes f and Queen
g5 checkin h5 but I took the pun okay
and actually it's hard to understand why
why play G for black obviously didn't
understand because like I'll take on g4
and what happens is you want to open
files diagonals and ranks to the
opponent's king this actually opens a
rank which rank does this open what's
that
v right just like dave chappelle you
plead the fifth okay so this this rank
is open and before there was there was a
black pawn there and it was all blocked
off and let's see which piece moves like
that all the rock so he played rook to
d5 now there's a tiny threat you
probably can't see it at home what about
you guys there's a tiny threat of rook
h5 check forcing king takes rook Queen
g5 mate and black has a lot of good
defenses he played the best one he
designed right the computer the computer
method is rookie five and then keep
sacrificing all your pieces okay also a
good defense dead and there's no way to
stop Rick h5 check and Queen g5 mate
much to the chagrin of Alex Marlar well
you could play Queen c1 but then your
rooks hanging yeah and in fact rookie
five is better than Queens according the
computer that's man the truth hurts
because after Queen sex throughout Queen
f8 mate is annoying yeah once the plans
not an f5 blacks King is really is
really shut off and I wonder had to see
this idea of Rick h5 check even when the
palm was on f5 how do you see that
okay so Rick g5 a brilliant move and
whites King is perfectly safe because of
the bishop on f1 hooray blacks King not
not as safe okay and black started with
the Queen on a5 which was terrible and
now the night on a4 is terrible King
safety very important when both sides
have a queen and a rook and even though
a wonder was only 12 when this game was
played he he understood that okay
another great wonder now this game is
very suspicious because a wonder won
this game when he was very young I think
9 or 10 and he was playing a grandmaster
just like you at home okay and they got
this position which the computer says is
equal but some positions are more equal
than others now this game was against
Grandmaster Larry Hoffman
okay and Larry Kaufman's a grandmaster
because several years ago he won the
world senior championship and they're
like you're a grandmaster
okay so they were like wow okay cool and
very suspicious reasoning all right but
that gets some of the stronger IMS who
are in their 50s and 60s to play in the
world senior you might become a
grandmaster in one tournament okay now
this is a very complicated position
because Black has a lot of pawns in the
center unlike white but why does it play
on f6 okay and white squee is either
good or it's trapped I'm not sure yet if
you're my
lecture you would know but you weren't
you're at home somewhere okay
so Larry Kaufman played Queen da he's
like oh boy
I'm going to trade Queens and not get
mated or I'm going to take the pawn on
our six
he's like either way is fine I like not
getting mated and I like taking the pond
at six unfortunately either one of those
happened what's that
he played rook takes six maybe blacks
saw that maybe not okay you can't trade
Queens now B then you're done at night
that's a bad end game if you play Queen
takes Queen Y plays rook takes Queen
okay so we take the rook and now if
you're a super computer you play the
right move and the game is about equal
and you play the wrong move that you get
beat really badly and they they say wait
you're not a super computer you made the
wrong move here well you're cheating
you're actually a human okay it's it's
the reverse of what they usually do and
even though black is a grandmaster he
played the wrong move here okay and you
know if I was in time trouble even if I
wasn't I think I would have a tough time
playing the right move and I know the
right move but dispositions tough and
this is funny a lot of times I'm playing
a tournament game myself and my opponent
captures something and I have two
captures that look sort of similar to me
I could take with epod of the C pawn or
me with at night and I don't know what
to do and I feel sort of silly looking
at it for like ten minutes when maybe my
opponent thinks one is really obvious so
what am I thinking about and this would
be one of those positions isn't the
right move obvious the answer is no all
right now we're going to vote and
there's only two legal moves okay and
both lose are very scary it's like the
election he probably won't cut that out
because I didn't say I didn't say Donald
I didn't say crazy Donald I didn't say
that he's a loon I said nothing I didn't
say any of that stuff okay I didn't say
that I'm not going to say that he said
that today even though he did okay well
this gives Bensimon something that it
out okay he's been doing he's been doing
that for the whole time also looked at
out because he said that today yeah you
know he said that right now we can vote
for either King f8 or King to H a and
remember one move loses immediately
which is cool the way you win
cool and the other one the computer says
is about equal although may I be afraid
to play both of them okay now we'll give
you an hour to figure it out because I
get paid by the hour so I'll teach Ben
Simon to leave now yet it's tough now
you get mad because you got nothing else
going on in your life I'll get mad this
free content okay who says King to f8x
clam raise your hand okay and who says
King h8 x clam and who abstains who
votes for a third party candidate hi
you're wasting your vote and most of you
didn't vote the higher rated players
were wrong and the lowest rated player
was right okay you're rated like 100 and
then your ratings ended up for like 4500
okay
yeah the strong players in the room the
2200 1200 they suggested to lose
immediately well the Grandmaster played
it so it's King age [ __ ] looks really
scary because you got 95 and Knight g5
and I have 7 the King's trapped in the
corner but that's the supercomputer move
King f8 actually loses immediately well
in a couple moves okay and that's what
he played okay Knight g5 threatening
Queen f7 million if you play Queen e8
stopping Queen f7 mate night h7 million
so he didn't play Queen e8
Queen c7 is legal didn't play that
either I don't think he played the
computer move rook a7 I liked playing
Rick a silent when it defends and
attacks okay all right so it looks good
looks like he's defending everything
rookie - Morphy style use all of your
pieces to attack now black is in Wing
Chun I mean zoogs Wong black can't do
Viswanathan it's true yeah you can't do
any of the whites pieces all over black
blacks King not safe White has
everything attacking blacks King Queen
to d7 trading Queens and easily winning
the endgame against a young you know
1900 rated 1800 rated I think a chair
was fee day
yeah now there's something in chefs
called overworked or as they said in my
lecture when you had your comments
overloaded I don't know what you're
talking about okay yeah the Queen on d7
is defending h7 and it's defending CA so
I can't do both and we have an x-ray
attack on the rook on CA so as the
person born in the century pointed out
Knight takes h7 check I hate when that
happens and black has one legal move but
that allows Queen takes CA check and
then that's not good
two legal moves yeah a little kids don't
know resigning is not a move the
quickest way to win that I can see which
doesn't mean it's the quickest is after
this we can always repeat always repeat
yeah and then here okay although it says
he played it says he played rookie seven
yeah a rookie seven really wins - is it
my meeting - Queen e6 now I wouldn't
play Queen e6 I would play Queen e6 than
Queen CA then Queen e6 and Queen yeah
repeat yeah it seems like a wonder
played rookie seven and this is also
pretty winning yeah he wanted to win the
Queen not give maybe one of the
torturers opponent while he was 1800 so
give him a break okay so that was a very
nice attack by white and for somebody
who's very young finding the sacrifice
on e6 and playing rookie to a quiet move
saying well you can't move anything
that's that's pretty impressive and yeah
black is just totally stuck here and
these are the kind of positions super
GM's like to have white where the king
is completely safe and your opponent has
no hope so a very nice game beating a
grandmaster under the age of we was
under the age of 10 sort of the youngest
being the oldest shocking okay now this
is not a win but that's okay he's
playing re an Atari who's the best
junior in in Norway and I actually see
it all the worldviews that he's always
fighting for first place I think he's 16
now I think and he's about 100 points
higher rated than me and he played on
the Olympic team for Norway and they
came in fifth
which is pretty good because board one
is carlson board two was Rufus board
three was dufus board for was the
triplet and board five was some guy they
found there at the Olympiad and they
still came in fifth and you're like is
it harm or good and the answer is now
yeah because and their players are very
suspicious after Carlsen but they came
in fifth and there you go
now this was a game so the big big
junior matchup here and lives good for
white and black played the move came to
d5 okay very suspicious now I know what
you're thinking at home you're thinking
is this video over got to go to the
bathroom you can pause okay so click the
pause button I'll let you find it you
can go to them and maybe get a snake on
the way back and then you can watch the
rest of the end game did you find the
pause button yet okay there you go
alright now here it's obvious to
everyone that white can win a pond by
playing and then what yeah we otherwise
why can't really do anything why can do
nothing and it's a draw or white can win
a pond yay and king b6 King takes a six
and wins how could a wonder make such a
blunder because it rhymes perhaps
perhaps not okay but unfortunately
White's King gets trapped on the a file
and luckily or skillfully black spawn
and you knew this was very important is
on g7 you knew that was the key if the
plum was on g6 plaque would be losing
yeah we have an extra tempo and a wonder
saw that he's like our I go in my pond
and I'll trap your king and he did and
of course you could move your king back
and forth forever that doesn't give a
lot of winning chances if I tried and
then a six and now black has one move
the draws you can do it g6 if the pawn
was already on g6 that would be bad and
we just stalemate in fact instead of
playing king a7 and drawing white drew
in a much funnier way g5 and
now black can let White Queen and win or
black can play h3 stalemate which is
what happened but it's very important
that in this position when I wonder play
King d5 he saw that he would trap the
white king white would lose a tempo and
then black could play g6 and keep the
King trapped so even though juniors
don't have good reputations for being
good at the endgame pretty good at the
endgame
he saw the way to the end and saw that
it was a draw and rook d6 also draws but
that's too simple
King d5 as much cooler all right now the
game you've all been waiting for
Fischer Kasparov oh wait no let's you
have to wait a little longer for that
this was a game against Danny Fernandez
who actually I gave lessons to before
you were born and he's an international
master who's played in the u.s.
championship and he's playing a wonder
who's eight years old okay just like the
kid that I taught today Luke how are you
yeah so sort of like you and you've
beaten many IMS and tournament play not
yet but you have a good excuse you
haven't played any items in tournaments
it's like an excuse have you played an
IM in a tournament game yes see that's
good see okay but you will because now
you're going to look at this game okay
so a wonder has the white pieces and
black plays a sharp Sicilian a good idea
against a kid okay and they play an open
Sicilian obviously okay now for the
crowd not free not for the smart crowd
at home they know the answer if white
plays a 5 what do you recommend for
black Queen a 5 check winning the pawn
so white played here in black stop d5
and even though white is eight years old
instead of playing Schubert super sharp
he plays Karpov style it should be to
Bishop III okay the most solid e5e5e5
then they don't listen to me then they
should tell them to play e5 if they're
reverse-psychology we work Luke very
good okay what me we can everything
horrible he played east six and e5
what no terrible no no don't teach chess
then they all play e5 when you crush him
he's just trying to beat you don't
listen him he was fired
okay so Knight to b3 Bishop e6 you're d1
and this is pretty boring play from
white but a wonder actually prefers slow
and steady the turtle method and then he
wins the race a for positional night b4f
for our attack takes takes d5 so blacks
playing very interesting which I don't
recommend against children but blacks
petitions fine
he 594 Queen c1 he saw his queen was
attacked pretty impressive
we can see seven otherwise white would
play Knight takes Knight and that would
be good for white Knight takes Knight c3
then I would recapture well I'll play c4
yeah
then it's less weakened then you might
get in trouble because you're pinned and
Bishop f3 and takes and c4 yeah this
seems pretty risky okay so Queen c7
takes takes rook takes Queen no longer
possible and this pawn is hanging on c2
Oh No Knight d4 defending the pawn
Bishop c5 pitting the knight c3 and this
game is very reasonable and probably
should end in a draw but white gave
black the sugar medium even though he
was eight takes takes Bishop g4 and
there's two bishops even at the age of
eight he's like two bishops yeah no
wonder likes to take on e6 okay I'm
going to I think I'm playing a wandering
norm tournament next month
don't hang my point on e6 okay yeah
remember the previous Bishop f7 Bishop
e6 then you can't take my foot well yeah
but if I play F takes e6 then I could
dj''q c6 I can still get in trouble
yeah that's what I would do but that
night on d5 is pretty good but should
not f4 is pretty bad what those moves
are all legal yeah what are you
suggesting Knight takes f4 is good but
it's okay okay
Knights except for is legal Queen b6
also legal defending the e6 pawn right
Bishop g5 yay c4 c4 is yeah text the
knight chicks f1 giving up the F file
Bishop e3 so notice how all the pieces
are hanging and when you're playing a
small child don't do that you want to
play positional and block up the center
and they're like what is this I've never
seen this all the pieces are hanging
that they've seen that they were hanging
their pieces before you were born and
you were born fifty years before them so
they're really good okay now Alex Mahler
would lose on time here with both colors
right you're like what Bishop e3 you'd
be so bad you'd be like what's happening
all right well it's Queens it too
actually moved it seems reasonable okay
and trade the pieces and it's clear now
that why it's doing well
why does the F file White has the center
pawns that are moving up White's King is
safer on h1 e 6 is hanging and not
defensible and if you trade on d5 I
could take an e4 is hanging so it looks
good for Wyatt and as you know at home
they don't know when you have obviously
call our bishops that's good for the
attacking side well there's Queens and
rooks and bishops on the board there's
good chances for checkmate
as we saw I wonder do another ok wait
more notes to myself if I wonder has a
queen rook and Bishop that's bad we
played rugby 5 and mated that guy it's
like a stop I wonder from taking on e6
alright this is my preparation for a
wonder okay so queen's eggs b2
this should take c6 check King h8 and
the winning move a wonder played at the
age of eight to beat the International
master was Queen age five by an eight
year old good job yeah
threatening Queen takes eh checkmate and
Queen takes bishop better than checkmate
because the guy has to suffer yeah yeah
so that's pretty good
played probably I am strength or so I
would say open Sicilian usually open
Sicilian when you're that young you
don't have a thousand games because when
you're really young every game is a
forty-five every game then when you see
Sicilian people are playing all kinds of
nonsense Bishop c4 unmoved - so open
Sicilian for an eight-year-old you
should have a lot of experience black
was a very experienced international
master and still he didn't get an
advantage with black it was an up and
down game and eventually White's attack
succeeded and black did not because of
the calculation and I think the key move
of the game was Queen d1 probably black
didn't expect that he was thinking all
the pieces are hanging White's going to
play Bishop digs III but Queen D one's
much stronger the Queen wants to go to
d7 we want to take the knight on d5 with
the opposite colored bishops black is in
a lot of trouble here and Queen takes b2
is obviously a terrible move in a very
bad position so very nice game from a
wonder when he was a probably the best
game out of all of them considering and
I've been told by the gawking rabble in
my audience that he's 13 now you agree
with that yeah so if he does play in the
World Youth starting next week even for
you he'll be in the world under 14 and
it'll be if he wins it'll be his third
gold medal and I remember a few years
ago when he was playing in the under 10
he was the highest rated American player
there and the under 10 by feed a rating
he was higher than under 18s we had so
his feed a rating is pretty high and he
came second the US Junior Championship
to Geoffrey Jean and only lost to
Geoffrey I believe so he's a real big
oil and hopefully we'll see him here
more at the chess club playing in
super-strong events that we have and
well he's definitely going to be
America's next grandmaster even if
somebody beats him to it we'll just say
they don't wonder did it alright so that
was chess of the 21st century I don't
think a wonder is going to play chess in
the 22nd century that's possible likely
but it's possible no that's not how it
works all right but good try that was
eight year old math there all right see
you all in December we're going to have
nem sova and yes or Sarah won as the
resident GM's hopefully they'll be
spinning around you need some more
rotation over there all right
Ben Feingold out